when to introduce with all credible
leaks regarding the final season of Game
of Thrones there are few confirmed
leagues but we also have season 8
spoilers in the form of alleged leaks
script pages Elite daily moon reached
out to HBO for comment on a possible
script League and the network declined
to make a statement the script appears
to giveaway plot points from several
episodes from Season 8 there are four
alleged script pages released 2 worst
somewhat close to each other in terms of
scene in that they're both setting
King's Landing around the same point in
the plot the other two are completely
unrelated and seemed to come much later
one involves the reveal of a character
as a white Walker the other is a
momentary happy ending
this page is appeared to be from
episodes 3 5 & 6 the latter of which is
the season finale in the last ever
episode of Game of Thrones in the
episode 3 pages from the supposed leak
during Lannister Arya Stark Sansa Stark
green of ptarth and the Hound erasing
throat cam that's been overrun with
whites the Hound is rhymed wagon but
they have company after the track II
blood rider who's been turned into white
Walker boards their wagon transcript
says the wagon goes careening toward
camp has the rundown tense the simmering
fires in the hordes of the undead the
hunt squints his eyes from the front of
the wagon he can barely see a thing the
snow is falling faster and thicker now
more than ever before the count says he
ins rains and urges the horses forward
greeting his teeth the wagon gives a
sharp wobble Tyrion falls back and
knocks his head against the wooden
railing Tyrion then says might I suggest
we go a little faster Clegane Alicia
Colin responds with if you want to dial
in stir your body welcome to jump off B
and then shouts look out The Hound leans
forward sees a blue-eyed figure standing
in front of the road then games the
reins to sharp jerk the wagon goes
crashing to the right Tyrion Aria sends
a Brienne and pod all topple under their
sides and go knocking into each other
Podrick lets his head then single finger
and warns the others saying we have
company everyone looks back at the edge
of the wagon we can see a single decayed
hand latch onto the wagon it digs its
nails into the wood then pulls itself up
revealing cano the tall jack the Trekkie
blood rider is no longer himself the
skin on his face is rotten and build
back bits of skeleton poked out of his
arms also decade he sets his blue-eyes
entire group of heroes and lifts his
Erik meanwhile the two page is said to
be from episode 5 which is penultimate
episode of the season and traditionally
the most action-packed scissors
Lannister and her brother Jaime having a
huge argument from the sound of things
winter has arrived in King's Landing
with the night king and the white walk
at the gates of the Capitol Cersei seems
to have Justin all locked up in her
dungeons while her sibling pleads with
her to listen to reasons and focus on
defeating the army of the Dead to make
matters worse it looks like Cersei could
burn down an entire city to stop John
and Danny from taking power on top of
that it also seems that Cersei may be
willing to completely obliterate King's
Landing her bed to get rid of the White
Walkers
it says Cersei pushed past Jaime in
towards the throne he turns on his heel
watches Cersei as she walks up those
steps a crazed look in her eyes it's all
too familiar for Jaime he asks her
Cersei what are you talking about
Cersei responds I'm talking about you
dear brother you who defended our
lecherous little brother you who
murdered our Father you who abandoned me
in a time of need and consulted with the
enemy Jaime trust convinced her see that
her true enemy is the night king he says
the nurse is not your enemy Jon Snow is
not your enemy the only enemies you have
to worry about her outside the city
gates right now
Cersei takes her seat at the throne
saying nothing Jaime inches closer to
his sister his face is contorted in a
look of desperate leading this has to
work jim says Cersei you are your
intelligent woman you may be jealous you
may be cruel but you know how to place
your bets
keeping the only man who can defeat
White Walkers in Chains is not a smart
bet Cersei responds with you would help
me release the usurper tell me after
that northern fool and his white-haired
defeated knight King what do you think
will happen to me Jaime answers you can
defeat the night king on your own only
sir she replies with can't I Jaime poses
racking his brain for what this could
mean and then it hits him Jaime then ask
Cersei if she is referring on wildfire
Cersei nuts Jaime asks are you sure we
have enough catapults amid sir she
responds with we won't be using
catapults along measure moment of
silence here Jamie looks sky burned and
to Cersei he shuts his eyes his worst
fear had been confirmed then he was seen
from the streets of King's Landing
Green & Hound are still riding through
the streets the city is in utter chaos
small folk are running this way and add
some clutching their family's clothes
others taking what good they can find
and stuffing them into their pockets
Brienne glances up on the horizon the
red cape Joe's closer and closer then we
are back in the throne room
Jamie starts walking up the steps of the
throne the mountain watches him closely
breathing heavily from under his helm
James says you can do this Cersei there
must be another way sir supplies there's
no other way the city gates will fall in
an hour
Jim Eden says innocent lives are at
stake here 1 million innocent lives
Cersei fidgets in her throne
uncomfortable and says to her brother
get
away from me unfortunately we don't have
a following page at the moment but we
can also what is going to happen next
Jamie already sacrificed his honor once
in order to save hundreds of thousands
of innocent lives by killing the Mad
King and has ever since been called the
Kings lair
however Cersei now intends to do the
same sure she would destroy the army of
the Dead by blowing up King's Landing
but she would also destroy most of the
living side it's also easy to assume
that the nor to this point either fell
or was bypassed since the night King is
outside the gates of the Capitol
preparing for the final attack and all
main characters are also present at
King's Landing
Jon Snow is in the same dungeons Ned
Stark once was imprisoned Jaime's
arguing with serfs in the throne room
the Hound and Brienne are riding towards
red keep anyways let's continue with the
leaked page from episode 6 it sees a
conversation between Tyrion Bram it
suggests that both survived events of
season 8 it also hints that bronze
witches sigh halfway through the season
and joins the matter of dragons and the
Daenerys ends on the air in her own
right at the end
Tyrion says I hear my brother promise
your castle on which Brown replies with
Oh a several times but not that he all
cons got himself killed
I'm reckon I'm not going to see neither
break nor mortar of any castle tyrion
says I wouldn't be so sure
Brown raises an eyebrow in heaps his
source to a halt bran surprisingly
responds with come again Tyrion states
you proved yourself a capable warrior in
the war of the dawn you helped vanquish
the night king and his armies he
single-handedly took out the golden
company in generals the Queen does not
forget your service despite past
grievances
bran replies that's one way to put it on
mysterion continues with nevertheless
Lannister always pays his debts
Tyrion leads he soars up to the crest of
the hill bran follows behind stopping
next to Tyrion to marvel at the defense
setting idle and undisturbed in the
golden sunlight Tyrion then says
consider the debt paid by sober bran
grins
inside the Train steering Brown cross
through the near deserted courtyard now
in many cases we might assume that these
are faked but there's a great deal in
their favour as being authentic first of
all they were leaked from the same side
that leaks in seven pages in the same
manner which turned out to be real all
the watermarks and black outlines
measured once we saw on season 7 leaked
pages there's a possibility that they
could be well done forgeries and
therefore we cannot say for certain they
are real until the show airs this leak
also gives the legend information on how
many pages there are per script one page
equals one minute of screen time episode
1 has 62 pages episode 268 episode 371
episode 469 episode 575 and the final
episode 83
this is in the line what HBO has said
about season 8 episode so being longer
than previous seasons more importantly
these alleged script pages are
supporting some claims that have been
floating around for quite some time as
real Intel from inside these claims were
not consider credible or probable until
the script pages turned up the claims
that are supported by leaked photos an
alleged leak through pages are King's
Landing is nearly destroyed by wildfire
and blow churning fire
we know the show is currently building a
King's Landing set to do live
pyrotechnics wildfire CGI pirate job or
at least it was in season six
but ringing fire is not at least in
season 7 HBO did live pyro some
speculated that Danny might turn to
fight Cersei after all but if this
alleged script is real the night king is
preparing to attack the capital and
therefore blue dragon fire destroying
the city makes sense the script page
also shelves Jaime learning that Cersei
is going to blow up King's Landing with
wildfire rather than let it fall which
supports claim from leaked plot that the
capital will be nearly destroyed by blue
drink fire and by wildfire the script
pages that I introduced you with earlier
in the video support the following
claims from the leaked plot Jaime kill
Cersei the mountain kills Jaime the
Hound and Brienne killed mountain it's
pretty safe to say that Jamie is going
to kill his sister while she gives an
order to Qyburn - as the Mad King used
to say burn them all it's also certain
that the mountain would kill Jaime while
the Hound with brains help who are
according to the script arriving at the
red cape would put an end to the
mountain along anticipated duel between
the mountain in the Hound often referred
to by fantastical gamble has seemingly
been set for the final season there are
a lot more major events in the league
plot but only these are currently
confirmed by alleged league script
regarding the other season eight
spoilers it's also been confirmed that
Fiona and the RA will reunite sometime
in season eight the production was
filming on a ship set in front of a
green screen which means they're filming
scenes set at sea the big news is that
this filming involved both lvl and an
actor that plays Theon and Gemma villain
and actress that portrays Yara the
actors were seen shooting with men
playing Ironborn followers it's also
important to highlight that an actor to
portray ceiran Greyjoy nor any
her main character was seen in this set
except for the two siblings
this means that Fiona and ER will
reunite sometime in season eight but
what we do not know is very novel fian
rescue yara from US captivity or Valera
perhaps escaped herself and reunite with
her sibling we also don't know whether
this scene takes place after yar has
been rescued or during the attempted
rescue linear says pregnancy on the
other hand beside being heavily for
share of the in the previous season has
also been confirmed in an interview in
which Game of Thrones showrunners David
and then are discussing the nurses
potential pregnancy with Kit Harington
an actor that portrays Jon Snow it
states the nurse says that she cannot
have children and you're like we'll see
about it only to run on the showrunners
left
speaking of major spoilers huge battle
for Winterfell has also been confirmed
by bunch of leaked photos from the
Winterfell set in money glass as we can
see for the final season the burdock she
has made for the very first time and
actual battlements and outer walls that
were in previous seasons set it in with
CGI HBO is also laying down why tarps
all over the place in preparation for
fake snow if there's not going to be any
battle scene filmed in Winterfell said
the production would not have to bother
with building actual walls with which
main characters and extras will interact
with neither will they have to have
aches no one's set unless real people
are going to march over it long story
short just I mean almost the entire
learning side will face hundred thousand
strong army of the Dead in front of
interval for the last polar according to
reliable sources there will be a big
meeting between the nerves and Sansa
Stark once Dani finally reaches